Trascrizione: Laura Pasquale
Revisore: Stefania Recchia
Non ci sono solo resurrezioni. Il titolo completo...
– io sono notoriamente un ritardatario –
è "Ossessioni materiali e resurrezioni digitali".
Io sono sin dalla più tenera infanzia
un cercatore di archivi e un cacciatore di storie.
Le due cose sono strettamente legate.
Ho passato l'infanzia e l'adolescenza
con la testa nei cassonetti
e ho trascorso momenti meravigliosi
in varie discariche italiane ed estere.
[Risate]
E vi parlo di un'ossessione.
"Ossesione" è il titolo del film del '43
di Luchino Visconti che narra
la torbida e casereccia storia d'amore
– si tratta di un libero adattamento
del "Postino suona sempre due volte" –
tra Clara Calamai e Massimo Girotti.
È una storia che li porterà alla rovina,
è una storia distruttiva che dimostra
quanto sia importante partire
dall'origine della parola.
L'ossessione ha una radice etimologica
legata proprio alla natura di "assedio",
l'essere incapaci di liberarsi da
un'idea fissa, totalizzante, che ci cattura
e che ci impedisce di agire e vedere lucidamente.
È una parente stretta di un'altra parola che
appare più o meno nello stesso periodo,
che è "mania".
La mania è il tentativo di dare,
fornire accettazione sociale
a quella che è, non è una pazzia furiosa, ma
al contrario, una sorta di dedizione totale.
E il '700 è l'epoca delle manie.
Ne trovate diverse: l'aeromania,
la cioccolatomania, la vulcanomania.
Qui vedete alcune immagini alle mie spalle
dalla copertina del bellissimo libro di Susan Sontag,
"The Volcano Lover", dedicato ad Hamilton, che è
il più grande collezionista inglese d'arte antica
e soprattutto un instancabile
frequentatore di vulcani.
Sino ad altre forme, anche quelle rovinose,
l'ultimo a destra, l'aeromania,
è la passione per le mongolfiere,
il più delle volte esplodono rovinosamente.
Il tema inizia ad essere trattato da i Medici,
che dicono, mah insomma, è giusto che
di queste passioni che rasentano la follia
si occupi la medicina, la medicina moderna.
Siamo a metà Sette (Settecento),
ci sono diversi titoli. Li vedete:
"Della mania, della frenesia, e della rabbia",
trattati in qualche modo legati
alle fibre sensibili, all'ipersensibilità,
la voce "mélancolie", che in qualche modo
si rifà ad antecedenti cinquecenteschi,
sino poi a il famoso trattato di Tissot,
eroe digitale noto non tanto
per questo suo leggendario trattato sui nervi,
quanto piuttosto è il primo studioso dell'onanismo.
Titolo, ovviamente, che gli ha
garantito notorietà internazionale
e poi diventa ovviamente anche lui
un inventore e propone questi rimedi,
– qui trovate due modelli di cinture
di castità unisex, tra i primi –,
[Risate]
che lo hanno reso in qualche modo
celebre tra i numerosi cultori della materia.
Questi trattati in qualche modo dimostrano
che l'ossessione e la mania hanno
due elementi che li accomunano, due limiti:
la ricerca della perfezione e la finitezza,
l'idea di completare una serie.
E in qualche modo si tratta di aspirazioni
che caratterizzano le vite e le opere
di moltissimi scienziati, moltissimi inventori, moltissimi creativi,
dei quali spesso si trascura questa dimensione,
si pensa che l'evoluzione sia lineare,
sia l'esito di processi razionali,
trascurando quanto la dimensione
personale molto intima di ossessione
sia stata determinante
per spiegare il loro successo.
E qui trovate esempi, vi ho citato
"The Volcano Lover" di Susan Sontag,
questo è il famoso vulcano di Turrell,
cui ha dedicato 40 anni,
un'opera di land art che consiste
nella trasformazione
di uno spazio artistico di un vulcano spento,
oppure, questo è un esempio di...
immaginate una persona
che dedica circa 20 anni della propria vita
a cavare da un blocco singolo d'avorio
21 sfere concentriche
che si muovono perfettamente,
correndo ovviamente
il rischio di fare quello che,
qui c'è un'affermazione famosa di Edison
sui 2.998 fallimenti prima di trovare la soluzione,
e in qualche modo la risposta che viene data,
il che fa il paio anche con esperimenti
che richiedono una tenacia particolare.
Avete visto che di recente, questo è l'esperimento
iniziato nel '27 sulla viscosità della pece.
Si sono succeduti 3 docenti, spesso sono morti
aspettando la caduta della
terza goccia o della quarta.
[Risate]
Nel 2000, quando è caduta l'ultima,
la webcam si era rotta.
Non tutti gli esperimenti
richiedono la stessa tenacia.
Qui trovate alle mie spalle uno dei
miei eroi digitali, Brian Berger,
che vive costruendo architetture di carta,
questa è l'ultima, sono 250.000.
E lui in qualche modo oggi propone repliche
di architetture cartacee evenemenziali
finissime, leggerissime e campa di questo.
Per molti innovatori, creatori e inventori
vale l'affermazione di una bellissima installazione
di Stefan Sagmeister.
Qui trovate il testo grafico:
"Obsessions make my life worse but
my work better", e quella che vedete
è l'installazione in scala: sono 250.000
monete da 1 centesimo,
vedete la scala, che sono state poste da
un gruppo di volontari coordinato da Stefan,
ci sono voluti giorni e giorni,
qui vedete una delle bambine,
dopodiché cosa è successo, è passata
una persona, ha sottratto un centesimo
e la polizia, per preservare l'opera,
le ha tirate su tutte e
e le ha riconsegnate nel giro di 2 secondi
a Stefan, che ci è rimasto male.
[Risate]
Il problema di fondo è che le ossessioni creative,
come narra l'installazione di Sagmeister,
possono raggiungere livelli patologici.
Qui ne so qualcosa.
E di fatti c'è una forma che è nota
come disposofobia, che è l'incapacità
di separarsi dalle cose, di distruggerle.
È l'altra faccia, in qualche modo,
del consumo compulsivo
della shopping addiction.
E questa patologia è nota anche
come "compulsive collecting disorder",
qui si torna alla dimensione collezionistica,
che in qualche modo riaffiora.
Si tratta di persone che seguono due binari:
alcuni non riescono a disfarsi di nulla
e muoiono difatti letteralmente
sopraffatti dalle loro collezioni,
cedimenti strutturali, assalti di migliaia di ratti,
ce ne sono diverse, è una forma molto diffusa.
Altri invece, non riescono ovviamente
a buttare via nulla nella loro esistenza,
ma fino a quando poi i solai e gli edifici crollano,
stipano e ordinano maniacalmente
tutto ciò che possiedono.
Si tratta di pratiche molto
simili a quelle collezionistiche.
Questa che vedete non è una collezione
di lattine di birra, è uno semplicemente
che raccoglie tutti i contenitori di alluminio,
fino a quando gli spazi sono saturi.
La disposofobia è nota anche come
"Sindrome dei fratelli Colliers",
due fratelli che vivevano ad Harlem.
Sono stati trovati morti nel '47,
sepolti nella loro casa,
in cui furono rinvenuti circa
140 tonnellate di oggetti diversi,
tra cui 25.000 libri, circa
14.000 quotidiani, 14 pianoforti,
[Risate]
1.500 palle da bowling, varie ossa animali,
uno scheletro umano, che dovremmo vedere,
qui vedete le immagini della folla,
tutto sulla Quinta, notate, eh?
Questo che vedete è il buco in cui viveva Homer.
Era rimasto cieco e il fratello gli passava
il cibo attraverso questa specie di foro
scavato in una grotta di giornali.
I fratelli Colliers sono diventati protagonisti
di alcuni bellissimi film, loro non lo sapevano,
erano già morti, ma avrebbero
probabilmente gradito l'attenzione,
perché hanno in qualche
modo posto la questione.
Qui c'è lo scheletro, si pensava fosse
quello di Homer, e in realtà non era il suo.
Qui trovate gli ultimi. Questo è
uno chassis di una Ford,
non si sa come sia arrivato fin lì,
ma comunque c'era.
[Risate]
Perché c'è un punto di contatto tra disposofobia,
collezionismo compulsivo e bibliomania.
E qui in qualche modo entriamo in medias res.
Molti bibliomani erano afflitti da disposofobia.
È una forma che spesso coincide con
la misoginia, non ammette altri affetti
che non siano quelli ovviamente
per i libri e per la carta,
e il tema centrale della mia riflessione,
e qui divento tempora(neamente),
provo ad essere serio, è che in realtà
noi dobbiamo la sopravvivenza
di corpi centrali dello scibile umano grazie
alla presenza di individui ossessionati,
che ovviamente in vita non sono mai stati gratificati
da alcuna forma di riconoscimento pubblico,
ma che invece oggi riconosciamo
come essere stati i protagonisti
di un fenomeno trasmissivo
delle informazioni decisivo.
I bibliomani, qui trovate il più famoso
bibliomane inglese, Phillipps, sognava
di possedere una copia di ogni
manoscritto esistente in Europa
e una di ogni libro stampato a metà Ottocento.
È un illegittimo, ma accumula un'enorme fortuna.
La spende fino a arrivare
al limite dell'interdizione.
Quando la sua casa, che è una casa di
diverse migliaia di metri quadrati,
non consente più il passaggio fisico,
chiede alla moglie e alle figlie di uscire.
[Risate]
Dice, mah, forse potreste trovare
una casa più comoda.
Loro accettano senza patimenti apparenti.
[Risate]
Warburg, forse molti lo conoscono per altre ragioni,
altro leggendario bibliomane,
gli dobbiamo la Biblioteca Warburg,
venne interdetto dalla famiglia,
la più importante famiglia di banchieri
erbaico-tedeschi europei del tempo,
quindi non era una persona che aveva
un problema di cash per comprarsi i libretti.
In ogni caso, grazie a questa sua passione,
ci troviamo di fronte quella che è
la più bella biblioteca
di studi rinascimentali europea.
Ora, per secoli, gli archivi e le biblioteche
sono stati luoghi in cui il sapere
veniva istituzionalizzato
e in qualche modo custodito.
È un'invenzione italiana.
Le biblioteche e gli archivi nascono
difatti dai tesauri medievali.
Si tratta di istituzioni legate alle corti
o istituzioni ecclesiastiche.
Quella che trovate sotto
è la Biblioteca Vaticana,
che è la prima in qualche
modo biblioteca europea.
Ma la cosa importante sono
gli elementi che li caratterizzano.
Cioè noi oggi percepiamo le biblioteche
come i templi del sapere,
i luoghi dell'accessibilità pubblica e totale.
In realtà non è così.
Le biblioteche, per funzionare,
per stabilire cosa è ufficiale,
e dunque cosa merita di essere
consegnato alla posterità,
di essere tradotto alla memoria,
richiedono in realtà degli accorgimenti.
Sono cioè luoghi chiusi,
fisicamente ben definiti,
con delle caratteristiche intimidenti
che tendono a dividere
e eliminare l'interazione tra gli umani:
il vincolo del silenzio,
il fatto di non poter parlare, il fatto
di non potere portare alcuni oggetti,
dividono, e soprattutto gerarchizzano,
cioè stabiliscono cosa merita
di essere conservato e cosa no.
Da questo punto di vista,
qui trovate alcune delle foto
bellissime di Candida Höfer
sulle biblioteche, ma trovate
anche alcuni archivi.
Io ho fatto l'archivista per quasi 6 anni.
È stato il momento più solitario e felice
della mia vita dopo le discariche.
[Risate]
Ma trovate in qualche modo un'immagine
che dà un'idea di un'infilata.
Pochi hanno mai visto
il ventre di un archivio,
pochi credo, sarebbe bellissimo
condividere questo sentimento,
hanno visto il ventre di una biblioteca.
Sta di fatto che quasi tutte
le biblioteche sono difatti depositi
velati da questa sottile necrofilia.
Quello che vedete alle mie spalle,
molti credo lo conoscano,
è Boneyard, che è il famoso cimitero
degli aerei, è quello che c'è a Tucson.
È un cimitero, come anche Calverton,
che è il più grande cimitero del mondo,
e, parlando di cimiteri, non posso non citare
l'immaginario cimitero degli elefanti di Tarzan.
Perché lo dico? Perché nella percezione comune
gli archivi e le biblioteche sono
luoghi polverosi, tristi, silenziosi,
archivisti e bibliotecari sono creature
dalla pelle vizza, dalle lenti spesse,
dai denti gialli, che in qualche modo
si muovono come il famoso topo di biblioteca.
In realtà le biblioteche e gli archivi hanno
sempre costituito degli spazi separati,
misteriosi, in cui erano custoditi i libri
e in qualche modo le fonti
che non potevano essere rivelate pubblicamente.
La Biblioteca di Francia creò "L'Enfer",
che era il luogo in cui erano custoditi i materiali
in qualche modo che non potevano
essere resi disponibili a tutti
e la British Library fece la stessa
cosa con "The Private Case".
Quello che vedete è Kearney,
che era il docente oxfordiano
che ruppe le palle per anni
per poter aver l'accesso,
dedicò 6 anni alla redazione
del catalogo di "Private Case".
Quando chiese di pubblicarlo, gli venne proibito.
Lo fece lo stesso, venne condannato,
dovette emigrare negli Stati Uniti.
Questo accade negli anni '50.
Cioè la censura, in qualche modo,
tocca questi aspetti sin dagli esordi
e in qualche modo si stabiliscono
delle gerarchie fisse
che l'avvento del digitale
ha rotto completamente
e ha consentito la resurrezione
di centinaia di miliardi di pagine
e di milioni in qualche modo
di autori, di storie, di vicende,
le più eccentriche, le più eterodosse,
quelle apparentemente sconfitte dalla storia,
perché se è vero che la storia scrive i vincitori,
il digitale in qualche modo ha mutato
profondamente questo concetto
e ci consente finalmente di conoscere
quelli che poi la storia
ci ha consegnato come comprimari
o figure del tutto neglette.
Cosa succede? Quelle che vedete
sono alcune immagini tratte,
questo è un panoplio, si pensava che
nell'emisfero orientale vivessero uomini
che si riparavano dal sole tropicale con un solo
piede che agitavano anche come ventaglio.
[Risate]
Quello che vedete sono esempi tratti a caso,
io potrei scrivere un breve articolo,
"Come Google Books mi ha cambiato la vita".
Questo è un trattato sull'allevamento
e il dressage dei gheppi.
Questa è la biografia del più famoso
uomo lupo cinquecentesco,
in realtà un uomo cresciuto
nelle Canarie e poi finito a Parma.
Quelli che vedete sono testi
sulla storia dei giganti,
con gli uomini più alti e più bassi di Francia,
e quelli che vedete sono parte delle
mie collezioni di trash europeo.
Perché si chiama "trash"?
Perché di solito era materiale
che finiva letteralmente nella spazzatura.
Cioè, noi ci dimentichiamo che per secoli
la cultura ufficiale ha stabilito
cosa poteva rimanere
e cosa poteva essere...
cosa poteva sopravvivere
e cosa doveva essere distrutto.
Tutti questi materiali non
li trovate nelle biblioteche,
perché negli anni li hanno regolarmente buttati.
Questo è uno dei miei prediletti,
questo crossover di generi
con Tarzan, movimenti da golpe borghese
e un improbabile uomo-ragno,
con ragno disegnato a mano.
[Risate]
Si chiamava Zimba, aveva anche
un'edizione canadese.
Questa invece è una delle
mie copertine preferite,
"Ho sedici anni e faccio la rapinatrice"
[Risate]
Ve lo dico perché fino ai
proto-manga degli anni '70,
la cultura trash in qualche modo, che
adesso è stata riconosciuta, nella sua...
ha in qualche modo
dimostrato che le barriere
tra cultura alta/bassa sono state rotte.
Vi posso confermare che
fino agli anni '70
era disdicevole scrivere di fumetti.
I fumetti erano dei prodotti per...
in qualche modo, sottosviluppati
e dunque non c'era biblioteca che li tenesse.
Voi cercate in qualunque biblioteca italiana
una collezione integra di fumetti per ragazzi,
non parlo di generi periferici, non li trovate.
Perché? Perché la cultura pop,
ma in realtà parlo anche di culture
scientifiche, di riviste trade,
erano considerati immeritevole
di essere consegnata.
Ora, Google Books ha
semplicemente scalfito,
ha digitalizzato 33 milioni sui 110 esistenti.
Ma i libri, non dimentichiamolo,
rappresentano una quota infinitesimale,
per dire, in due copie del
Corriere della Sera ci sono,
c'è l'equivalente della quantità
di carta di "Guerra e Pace".
Quindi, se è vero che in 7 anni sono
stati digitalizzati 33 milioni su 110,
la quota che rimane è ovviamente
ben lungi dal colmare.
C'è un'illusione nella digitalizzazione,
ci vorranno secoli.
Per farvi un esempio, in Italia ci sono
5.620 archivi e 13.000 biblioteche,
escluse le scolastiche.
Gli archivi di stato custodiscono
1.300 chilometri di scaffali.
Ci sono circa 1.300.000 metri di
documenti che corrispondono circa
a 13 miliardi di fogli, fronte e retro,
sono 26 miliardi di pagine.
E stiamo parlando di una quota microscopica
degli archivi di stato italiani.
Dunque, per concludere, il processo
di digitalizzazione appena iniziato
ha finalmente rotto
il principio dell'ufficialità
e ha infranto una gerarchia
che è rimasta immutata per secoli,
liberando generi, personaggi e storie
che sono una formidabile fonte di ispirazione.
Noi tendiamo a dimenticarci quanto
sia interessante imparare dagli errori,
osservare chi ha avuto un pensiero laterale,
fino a pochi anni fa non era possibile, perché,
salvo rarissimi casi, non era possibile
accedere a questo patrimonio.
Oggi invece la riscoperta che è appena
iniziata ci consente finalmente
di riprendere questo lavoro di scavo nel passato.
Noi siamo sempre protesi in avanti,
ma ci dimentichiamo
della quantità di idee e di ispirazioni
che il passato ci può dare.
E con questo ho finito.
Grazie.
[Applausi]